*Triumphant music* -Once upon a time in a far away land there lived a beautiful girl who dreamed of finding her prince.
-Alas, real life is no fairy tale. Here's why Disney princes... -Prince: So, this is love. - Would make terrible boyfriends
*swish* Prince: My dad threw this party so I could meet a girl who's... Girl: Emotionally independant... Prince: Hot, and rich like us
Prince: So, will you marry me? Crowd: Awww. Girl: I think I left my straightener on.
*Tripping sound*
*cameraphone clicks*
*Swish*
*Chimes*
Hey, hey, hey, hey, Hey!
Girl: What are you doing? Prince: Oh, thank god I thought you were dead.
Girl: Then why would you try to kiss me? Prince: Uh, hold on. Don't try to change the subject. Who are these seven guys texting you?
Girl: Uh, they're just my roommates.
*Chimes*
*Dramatic music*
*Swish*
*girl grunts*
Beast: So now that we live together we need to establish a few ground rules.  Girl: Actually I'm a little hungry.
Beast: You are not allowed to step foot into that side of the house. Especially my room. Ever. It is forbidden.
Girl: Okay, does that include the bathroom... Beast: Also, I'm going to need to know where you are and what you're doing at all times...
Beast: Because sometimes I get lonely. Do this and I'll release your father from my basement.
Girl: You kidnapped my dad? Beast: Nailed it!
Girl: Who are you talking to?
*Chimes*
*ocean sounds*
*soft flute music*
Eric: Uh, excuse me, miss? Have you seen my girlfriend?
Girl: Eric, it's me. Eric: You look familiar. Wait, I follow you on Twitter right?
Girl: You don't remember the crazy lady you stabbed with a boat for me?
Eric: I think I know what the love of my life looks like. Girl: Even your dog knows it's me.
Eric: Let me get my dog back. Reina? Where'd you go?
*piano music*
Naveen: Oooh, sorry babe. Think you can spot me? Girl: Again?
Naveen: My parents just cut me off. Girl: No you need to get a job. Naveen: Hahaha! I got a job
Naveen: My music. You woke up like that. You woke up like that. Flawless.
Girl: You know what? Have fun making love to your mini guitar.  Naveen: It's a Ukelele.
Naveen: Can I at least borrow your car to get home.  Girl: Take the bus!
Naveen: *sings* You're so fancy. You already know.
*Chimes*
Girl: Wait, your name is not Ali?
*Dramatic music*
Aladin: *sings* Prince Ali, no Aladin, yeah that's me a compulsive liar, someone who plunders.
Girl: Uh, why are you singing? Aladin: *Sings* I told you what you wanted to hear to get inside your cave of wonders
Girl: My cave of what now? Aladin: The mansion we slept in is one that I crept in, the way I get laid is through deceit.
Girl: Who are you people? Aladin: The car that we road in was one that I'd stolen but who needs a ride when you live on the street?
Girl: You're homeless? Aladin: That monkey you swear follows us everywhere is my one and only friend
*Monkey howls*
*Chimes*
*Chinese music*
Girl: So yeah, I've had the absolute worst luck with dating lately. How about you? Shang: This is a little awkward. I kind of thought you were a dude.
Girl: Excuse me? Shang: It's just from certain angles, and your hair is pulled back in these photos. Girl: I have boobs.
Shang: Yeah, sorry. I guess I made a man out of you.  Prince: I have been looking everywhere for you.
Girl: You know what? I'm done with Disney princes. Being single never bothered me anyway.
Narrator: And she lived happily ever after.
Prince: Why does this always keep happening to me? Shang: Hey, how you doin'?
Beast: Ladies love it when you kidnap their fathers.
Beast: I'm gonna build her a library if you know what I mean. And by that I mean I'm actually going to build a library.
Girl: Seriously, who are you talking to? Beast: I'm talking to Lumiere!
*Mock Disney music*